I had a dream last night that it was the best episode we've ever done.
So, I couldn't sleep the rest of the night, got in here, fired up the old machine, and I'm now waiting on these guys, and I am loose.
I got a little bit of a sweat going. The hammies are pliable, flexible, and the jaw muscles are ready to really ask some tough questions and giggle at my funny little friend, Sean and Will. Guys, welcome to SmartLess.
SmartLess. Hi, guys. Shut up, Sean. Oh my god. I've never laughed so hard as I did today.
Today, when we were standing on the street, we'd just come out of a meeting, the three of us adults. Sean starts to say something, and he undoes the top of a bottle of water, he's about to take a sip, and Jason slaps it out of his hand. It lands on the ground.
Just a fun little hair pull. Yeah. Just a little fun. Just a plastic bottle. Nothing broke. Plastic bottle. So I reached down to grab it because it falls at my feet. I hand it to Sean, and as he reaches for it, I just drop it right before he can grab it. Like, it's Sean, that's twice. That's twice denied water.
As it lands on the ground, Sean reaches down to get it, and Jason kicks it. It goes flying, hits a curb, and goes under a parked construction truck. It explodes. The top comes flying off. The water's everywhere. Fucking funny. I haven't laughed that hard.
It felt like high school all over again. It was a little bullying. Just fun and stupid. God, I love it. Fun.
Jay, did you like my cheesecake last night?
Yeah. I would've liked it a little firmer, Sean.
A little. It was a little too fluffed. It wasn't as gooey as the last one, so I feel like we're making progress. I say this as a person who can't even boil water. So the fact that you cook anything is incredible. It's impressive. But also, I didn't know, Will, that I didn't know how to make whipped cream. I didn't know you just pour half and half or whatever in a bowl and whip it. My mind was blown this time.
Do you think it's a good idea that you've now learned how easy it is to make whipped cream?
I think so. I think you know what I'm doing tonight.
You missed out on a good cheesecake last night.
Sean told me the secret ingredient that he drives an hour and a half for.
It was a British white chocolate bar.
No, not Cadbury. Another brand called Milky Bar.
Is that normal that there's a white chocolate candy bar in most cheesecakes?
No. I just melted it to make the creamy part. It was one of many ingredients.
I was obsessed with getting the ingredients right. I drove an hour and a half to get it because they don't sell them in the US.
What did you do while you were there? I went to Portillo's, a rare joint we don't have near us. I had a big burger, a shake, fries, and a hot dog.
Wait, you got a shake for lunch? Yes, and two beef sandwiches. Were you buying for all the kids in the school bus? No. I bought extra stuff and put it in the fridge.
Let's get started. Today, you're gonna freak out. It's my guest today. I got my favorite redheaded firecracker here today. She's a self-proclaimed computer nerd and before becoming a full-fledged movie star, she made websites for free. At 14, she did a PowerPoint presentation titled Project Hollywood to convince her parents to let her drop out of high school and move to LA to pursue acting. Thankfully, that dream came true. Her name is Emma Stone.
Emma Stone. Emma Stone. Come on. Emma's a little under the weather. I'm a little under the weather. That's so can't believe you showed up for us. Did you get into a big pile of bad cold? You've been there, right? We're saving a seat for you. I'm in a hotel. Emma's been up for four days.
I don't think of you as a ginger, but you are. I'm blonde right now. I was born blonde. I dyed it red for a long time. People thought it was natural, but it wasn't. My mother's natural redhead.
Do you need a second? Take a nap. I've been up for days. Didn't you dye your hair originally because you weren't getting parts? Yes. I moved to LA at 15. Roles for 15-year-old girls were mostly blonde cheerleaders, and I didn't fit. So I dyed my hair brown to stand out. How'd that go? I didn't get parts after that either.
A couple years later, I auditioned for Superbad. Judd Apatow suggested red hair because the other girl had brown hair. So we dyed it red, and the rest is history.
Was Sean's research accurate? Were you really doing websites? I was into primitive HTML in the late 90s, building drop-down menus and such. I don't have a computer now. They lent me this one for this interview. I'm a neo-Luddite now.
What do you look for in a drop-down menu? It needs to be clear and fun. No Comic Sans, only Helvetica. You don't have a computer at all? I have an iPhone 15. Is this an ad for the iPhone? Mama, was there heavy rotation on it?
No social media? No. I think a global six-month social media break would be a great reset. People would learn to manage boredom, a lost talent. Do you ever look around and see everyone on their phones? Yes, sometimes it's reflexive, from nervousness or insecurity.
What's your morning computer loop? I check the New York Times, email, and calendar on my phone. But you have no reason to get out of bed. I sleep in a pile of feathers.
Which of your projects shall we talk about? Let's talk about childhood. It was your birthday last week. Happy birthday. Can we guess your age? 25. I'm 37. You don't look 37. We worked together when I was 19.
You were in The Rocker. The cast was hilarious: Rainn Wilson, Jason Sudeikis, Bradley Cooper, Fred Armisen, and me. I was there for a week; you were there for a couple of months. I played the bass in a band, kind of like School of Rock. Will played the lead singer of a hair band. You've been consistently doing great work since then. Not a lot of people have never done a bad movie like The Rocker.
I met you once briefly at SNL. Your real name is Emily. Why did you change it to Emma? I worked at a dog bakery when I was a teenager.
There's a dog poop pickup company in Scottsdale called Poo Patrol. I worked at Three Dog Bakery at The Grove when I moved to LA at 15. Your name was taken at Screen Actors Guild, so you changed it. I originally changed it to Riley but then to Emma, after Baby Spice from the Spice Girls. Albert Brooks' real name is Albert Einstein.
I broke my shoulder the night before the Spice Girls concert in 2019. I broke my toe yesterday getting out of the shower. I've broken seven bones before 30.
You have a million-dollar voice. I was colicky for five months as a baby, which gave me a raspy voice.
I have a two-and-a-half-year-old daughter. I met my husband Dave McCary at SNL. We got married during the pandemic.
You have a new show with Nathan Fielder called The Curse. You made the movie Poor Things with Yorgos Lanthimos. It's probably my favorite thing I've ever done.
Three things I always keep with me: Coke, apples and peanut butter, and Starbucks coffee. You were phenomenal in The Favourite. The hardest thing I've done was stage acting in Cabaret. I broke a bone and am extremely blind without contacts.
What do you do when you get hiccups? I stick my finger down my throat to gag and throw up a little. It works. I have a poorly done tattoo on my wrist that bleeds out more every year. Justin Theroux suffers from eczema.
I grew up in Scottsdale, Arizona. After winning the Oscar for La La Land, I went straight to work on The Favourite.
If I had gotten up for The Rocker, I'd thank Will first. You worked with Zach Galifianakis in Birdman. Are you watching Golden Bachelor? Thank you, Emma Stone. Feel better.
She has a great work ethic and has never called in sick. She's in the category of actors who have never sucked. I love Birdman too. Bye, everybody. SmartLess.